- [Narrator] Every time
you use your credit card,
a whole series of behind the
scenes steps and fees kicks in
so you can get-
(machine beeping)
But this system has been
getting more and more expensive.
- Okay, your total will be 14.85, please.
- [Narrator] This $15 lunch
probably cost the shop
around 37 to 46 cents in various fees.
It adds up and it's why
this place prefers cash.
- We have the cash sign so
that we don't have to pay fees.
We save money.
We save money on every sale.
- [Narrator] Some businesses
are even starting to implement surcharges
adding around 3% to your bill
if you pay by credit card.
And now Congress is getting involved.
- Swipe fees just aren't
annoying to the retailers.
They're anti-competitive
- [Narrator] Here's how the
credit card fee system works
and what Congress is trying to change.
Your credit card involves
two main companies,
your bank, which loans you the money,
and the card network
that handles the transaction
like Visa or MasterCard.
Those two companies handle the
most credit card transactions
in the U.S.
When you use your credit card,
the transaction runs through
a store's processing system
through the credit card's
network to your card's bank.
And there are fees throughout these steps.
The processing systems fee
is generally fairly low,
around one 10th of a percent
of the total purchase.
There's a large market the
merchant can choose from,
which can keep this cost down.
Then there's the credit
card's network fee,
around a quarter of a percent.
And the largest fee of the
system also happens here.
The interchange fee, it's
usually around two to 3%.
It's set by the card networks
but it's paid to your bank
that issued your credit card.
- You get rewards for every purchase
- Everything?
- Essentially, that fee
helps to fund the rewards
that we all get when
we use our credit cards
- Earn 5% on travel
purchased through Chase
with Chase Freedom Unlimited.
- Cashback credit cards
or credit cards with
miles for travel benefits,
someone's paying for that.
It can be only a few cents
or maybe a few dollars
but then, think about
how much that adds up
when you take into account
all transactions being made.
- [Narrator] Merchants pay banks
and other credit card
issuers interchange fees
set by Visa and MasterCard,
roughly 55 billion just last year.
Interchange fees vary by card.
Generally a higher rewards card
will come with a higher interchange fee
and businesses have
little control over this.
They can't choose to not
accept a high rewards card
because of the fees.
If they want to accept any
of a network's credit cards,
they have to accept all of
that network's credit cards
- In the end, what ends up playing out
is that because the
interchange fees are hefty,
merchants build that in
to the sticker prices
that we all see in many cases,
regardless of how we pay.
So the cash shopper
and the credit card shopper
are often paying the same price
but the credit card shopper's
getting the rewards.
- [Narrator] If a credit
card network raises fees,
which they did on many
purchases this year,
businesses have few choices.
It's these rising fees
that has Congress wanting
the credit card system
to look more like the debit card system.
When you use your debit card,
the transaction looks similar.
It runs through the source processor,
through a card network, to your bank.
But in 2010,
Congress passed the Durbin
amendment, that same Durbin.
It lowered and set a cap
on the interchange fees
that card networks
could set for many banks
and it made banks enable a second network
that merchants could use,
instead of the card network
that's on the front of your card.
- So the idea here is merchants
should have the choice
of being able to choose
between the more
affordable of the networks.
So if sending the
transaction over the network
that's not Visa or MasterCard
is cheaper for the merchant,
then why shouldn't it be able to do that?
So it was essentially
meant to inject competition
into the debit card
space while also enabling
for lower costs potentially for merchants.
- [Narrator] And that's what a Democrat
and Republican senator want
to do to the credit system.
Their bill isn't imposing
to cap on the fees,
but it would require larger banks
that use Visa or MasterCard networks
to enable a second network
to make it competitive
like the debit system,
which should lower fees.
Banks and credit card companies
aren't thrilled about it.
- There's a potential ripple effect here.
If the banks are receiving
lower interchange fees
than they currently are,
and interchange fees
are funding credit card rewards programs,
what would happen to
those rewards programs?
- [Narrator] Banks are concerned
that this legislation
would limit the amount
of rewards they could offer.
And the networks also argue
their fees go towards things
like network security and innovation.
Merchants, especially small businesses
are concerned that the increasing
fees are becoming too much
on top of already rising prices.
- There are two sides to this argument.
Credit cards incentivize people
to spend more than they otherwise would.
Credit cards result in more sales
than merchants would otherwise get.
And there are also costs associated
with not accepting credit cards.
Like if you're a cash-only business,
being concerned about cash
theft and other issues.
On the other side, the
merchant industry is saying,
"Yeah, but our costs continue to rise
as credit cards become
more and more common
for consumers to use when they're shopping
and fees increase."
- [Narrator] Businesses have few options
to offset these rising fees.
So more and more places are
passing them along to consumers.
So if the price to use credit
cards continues to go up,
so might your lunch.
- Thank you so much.
Enjoy your chicken par.
- Thank you.
- Have a good day.
(funky techno music)